Tình bạn hơn 3.6 dưới dưới đình ông và gia tập thủ tưởng thái lan phía tổng tàn xin ở trời đã tàn dưới.
Sau khi một quan trức cảm phù chia rò gì, nổi giung của định đàn dưới hai bên ông Hú xen nói,
quan trức này hành động vì bức xúc trước lời lẽ xúc phạm, nhắm vào tôi và thủ tưởng hút mà nét,
hình không nhiều gió ai là người xúc phạm và cũng không tí lộ dành tính người rò gì.
Ông Hú xen cũng giác lại chuyến thăm cảm phù chia của bà phía tổng tàn Hú tháng tư khi hai dưới đình gó bội gặp thân mặt.
Hì đó bà phía tổng tàn tình gói một xem lại các càng phòng trước đây,
cha và cô dột bà tình gỷ lại tại từ dình hồn xen khiến vũ sò gì đoạn ghi âm đang khiến chính phủ lưới mình của bà phía tổng tàn,
đứng trước người có xúc lộ.
Trong tròng hiệm mà có ông Hú xen là chú,
lông thời quyền ông không nên để tâm đến phê đối lập thái lan trong đó có tư lần quân khu hai,
buồn xin, bắt lăng, sau đó bà phía tổng tàn đã công khá xin lỗi khẳng định đây là trên thất đàn phán
và mong hồn xin phủ của cộng đối với tục hợp tác vì anh đến cú ra.
Theo hú xen, cú điên đàn kéo dài mười bài phút sau dây,
dễn ra tối mới làm thằng sau có sự thằng ra phíanh dịch của phó lâu trường.
Đông pênh, hú xen cũng chưa xe bản hiêm cho khoảng cá mính người trong trí phủ của cộng đối cầm buồn xe.
Tuy nhiên, việc gọi điên bây giờ gì đã rơi làm sông trí trách tại Thái Lan.
Hẹo qua là ngày mẹ tạm thằng sau, đàn phủ dơ thái,